babe yeah you can't come with us in the
car okay
what you can't come with us in the car
it's okay just everybody's doing this
lately
i know but i don't want the baby without
a car seat
ariella and binium's cultures clashed
so much during this episode
it was literally one thing after another
yes ariella made binion walk home from
the hospital
with the baby because they didn't have a
car seat
and once they made it home ariella
watched binium's friends
and family slaughter a sheep she was
traumatized and to make matters worse
they slaughtered the sheep for her
it was all for her sit tight because
that was just the beginning just wait
until we get into the aunties
in their unfiltered opinions
hey 90 day fans fam it's malicia
the latest episode of the other way was
full of progression
a lot of the couples made some progress
but some people had to deal with
rejection jenny found herself getting a
little too impatient
when it comes to submit proposing so
she took a step that eventually
backfired on her
i'm embarrassed that smith just shot me
down like that
his reaction just wasn't what i was
expecting at all
plus britney revealed that she is
officially
divorced yes
finally all right well before we dive
deeper
into that let's go ahead and join binium
and the baby on their walk home so how
he go
he's gonna walk
um
i think i'm with binium on this one
now just for some context having a car
seat in ethiopia is not
mandatory that's why benjamin was so
okay with it
i get ariella's concern but
i don't think she thought this one
through i personally would have felt
better being able to
see my child then having him walk
through the middle of a busy city
in the heat but ariela did what she
thought was best at the time
she just heard no car seat and she said
oh no car
oh my god isis
ariela who just had a c-section
arrived home only to find that binium
invited people to the house without
telling her
on top of that she had absolutely no
clue
that she was about to witness the death
of a sheep
this is for you for the gifts
oh my god he's so afraid this is not
what i wanted to see right now oh god
i'm just waiting i'm literally at a loss
for words
in the u.s i feel like people might send
a fruit basket they wouldn't kill the
sheep
right in front of me i was sad for the
sheep
i get that slaughtering it as a welcome
gift is part of binion's culture
but he should have taken into account
that it's not a part of hers
the least he could have done was warn
ariella he might need to take another
walk
this time without the baby
why do you do the thing with the sheep
this culture like
for god sacrifice like something for
your happiness
so okay baby come on this is just like
awful because
it's not about full party right now i
don't know
but i don't want to see it die because
everything is for you
and for come on i think that makes it
worse
now i'm responsible for sheep's
slaughter well
while ariella was still coming to terms
with being the reason a sheep had to die
in comes binium's ants
[Applause]
and they didn't waste any time getting
to the conversation about
baptizing that baby uh are you they ask
you
he's gonna baptize or no
you can tell them though i mean
we talked to someone i don't we don't
know if he can baptize him because i'm
not
a christian so yeah the aunties
were not going for that answer according
to them
the baby can be baptized in binium's
faith
without ariela being christian
we find the priests they will do for us
i feel like they said a lot more stuff
they definitely did
at this point things seem to get a bit
awkward
so binium's aunts decided to leave so
ariella could rest
finally shortly after this conversation
though
ariella came to a decision i feel
obviously like you're putting pressure
on me
to do something i don't really want to
do
having a baptism is not part of my
religion i don't believe in hell and
that's the whole purpose of the baptism
to
avoid having your baby go to hell i
don't think sweet innocent little babies
go to hell
i'm thinking you're just you know just
just one existing you guys are going to
be so happy if i do this
silly thing like for me it's silly i'm
sorry but it's silly
but i know it's so important for you you
know
if you want to baptize a baby i'm not
gonna say i'm happy about it
but
so if you can do it you can do it if you
want if you really want you can do it
if you thought things were going to be
good from this point
on of course you were wrong
just a week later ariella and binium
took the baby to the doctor
to get vaccinated and circumcised
ariella
cried her way through the vaccinations
but when it came to the circumcision
she just couldn't do it she
no don't touch him well look at him he's
finally he has some peace today after
being upset all day i don't wanna
miss peace are you kidding me
no i'm not kidding just do not don't
don't put him
hey no i'm not comfortable
just do whatever you watch
[Music]
the patient is waiting for me okay you
know what you can wait for a second i'm
getting his clothes on so i can take him
and that she did she took the baby
and left hopefully she changes her mind
and comes back well in the meantime
samid
and jenny gave us a little bit too much
information
when it comes to their love making sesh
so after smith stood up for me against
his parents
i wanted to show him how proud and happy
i was
so how was it
it was good like i like it it's
wonderful to be intimate with the man
that i love
he makes me feel like i'm beautiful
that's my man he's my submit
it was amazing baby
i love you lovely too oh man
a making love was passionate now she can
totally dominate ring like kind of thing
that's what i like
i just can't get over jenny in that hair
flip
yes she is filling herself unfortunately
it didn't take too long for that
confidence to turn into
embarrassment jenny attempted to give
submit a promise ring
to show her appreciation for how hard
he's fighting for their relationship
and well he gave it back
i don't think that it was a time for a
ring because
i'm not divorced and every ring is very
important
in india we do a ring ceremony
it's a kind of promise ring so we
promise in front of everyone not
just in the best so when are we going to
have this
ceremony after your traverse is final or
what
i need to check out check it out my life
was can i get engaged with before my
hand it works or not
otherwise i can like um i love to do it
as soon as like
possible like jenny patience is key
girlfriend
you've come this far you might as well
hang in there a little
while longer speaking of divorce
britney is finally a free woman
and next week she heads back to jordan
although she and yazan are still on
rocky turns
love you love you too i'm finally
heading back to jordan
and i need to decide once and for all if
yazan is
truly committed to changing
what have you done for me or this
relationship it doesn't matter
about that it doesn't matter
i don't need to go all the way to jordan
and get those answers
plus devin seeks answers from jihoon
about whether or not he's been faithful
i noticed you were looking at naked
girls i have this feeling that i can't
shake that he wasn't faithful to me when
we were long distance
have you ever cheated on me
i'm not sure if jihoon would actually
confess to that
but i guess we have to wait and see all
right 90 day fans fam
make sure you stick with et because as
usual we
are covering it all i'll see you next
[Music]
time